oh just as soon as anyways Hulk come off
the table you can't use the power of
veto on the same movie two weeks in a
row
don't care I'm not sitting from that
thing yeah it's not that bad one of the
most underappreciated comic-book movies
ever made great now you got him started
it's an insightful look into the psyche
and makeup of a misunderstood monster it
delves deep and examines the sins of the
father paid for by the son this just in
nobody cares all anybody wants for my
movie is wanted to structure my big
green steroid freak he threw a tank
across the desert once in two hours in
18 minutes look nobody wants to
hopefully daddy issues they wanted to
beat up big freakin monster [ __ ] monkey
paw
poodle and I would just want somebody to
explain to me what happens in the last
fights guys I only carry so much Tylenol
on me
all right hook comes off the table but
only if Adam West's Batman does oh man
that's fair I wasn't gonna vote for
either one of those anymore right all
right and I'm formerly be doing ghost in
the shell' what I think we should remove
animation from comic book movie night
altogether you did not just say that oh
I could put mask of the phantasm in
return of the Joker up against any
Batman you haven't come out on top
cabbie
breathe breathe I'm not saying they're
bad movies but come on they're made for
kids and Rocky Horror Picture Show was
made for sexually confused drag queens
yeah but I look over at the wall there
it is or is there something you're not
telling us okay guys you know I think
manga adaptation should be excluded all
together to that I say old boy
I would sacrifice even that movie if it
meant that I never had to see another
identical anime face ever again okay I
mean can you just tell me why they all
look exactly the same
they do not big eyes pointy noses crazy
hair adult men who look like 12 year old
girls women who dress like dominatrixes
teenage girls who wear outfits that
would make a pedophile sweat I mean what
the hell okay you know what I'm going
out there for a beverage when I come
back you two either need to have this
sorted out or one of you needs to be
dead walk lazily isn't it every single
hi-yah games are just bad robot
thanks Glenn John Drury Americans tend
to go for rape and oppression turn out
the gun she and all I hear is Sochi
Sochi so we going with Akira goes to the
show or vampire hunter D D you know when
I said whatever you needed to be dead I
was kidding he's fine okay so it is
vampire hunter D by means of persuasive
violence illustrated novel not my comic
book